ん
このチョコエッグん
何か嫌な予感がするパッケージのクリーチャーの方に釣られて買ったもののこれは
まさか
フェイクいやマンてまだ疑うの早い
なぜなら販売元か触れた送風ただや古田
あの大手お菓子メーカーが古田さんだよこれは間違いない各税この禁断の空の向こうに
はわれらのフューチャーパッケージに記載したらクリーチャーともに vg または
同様の雰囲気が入っていると見て動向だ
なぜを笑っている者なんてこれは5割
のない映画をこの空気獣から書全摘もらった感じラメ大丈夫大丈夫
山字だとどういうことだ今この魂をに自らの運動エネルギーを9倍で1エネルギーを
上昇させた結果掃除たわずか0.01秒の振動によって生み出された音波が自分の耳に
伝えたメッセージは者らじゃーっ
ということざんざ音一で渡すのかペットを完全にひっくり返しタバコの禁断の卵はどう
いうこと
どういうことだ何が起きている t 時期が落ちているこの時点で考えられる状況は2
つ一つは一つは中にあるフィギュアが何者かの手で子供のにだいぶ破壊もしくは
ペディア自身がご乱心のために次回を図り命を絶ったけ
つまり破壊して
もう一つフィギュア入っないそしてさっきから私が不信感を抱くのはただ1つ
パッケージに見える黒聞き物音にも角質のハイトーンカラーの桜
これはオーブではなくチヨコレイトなのかやばい前今さーん言えないぜー
実は実は箱買いしてたんだぜーぃ母校日付
とりあえず卵を取り巻くポリ塩化ビニール通称 pvc 塩化ビニルモノマー c 2
c h 65して構成される特色人の除去作業フェーズはに入る
なんだこの
活断層